不讲风控的啊
每个人不一样的
但是有一个原则
我就跟你们说过了
真正好的单子
它是不会打你自损的
这句话你要记进去
往往正确的
优秀的盈利单
它不会打你自损
明白了打个一
这句话背后有两层含义
就真的要让你赚钱
你当然也挡不住
懂了吗
谁也挡不住你
他就是要给你钱
你就设在那
比如说我现在进场
我就挂了
止损我就挂了一点
然后我心里面就默念
有本事你打我止损
来
我把头伸过去给你看
你给我是你看我
砍了我认
common
要有这种胸襟
给你的
比如说我这两千美金准备好给你了
你拿去
今天不拿
明天不拿
不拿就算了
你还给我钱
对吧
今天一千
明天两千
到后天翻倍了
哎
这个
受从若惊了啊
太好了
对吗
这就是我们得便宜了
对不对
我们得到便宜了
原本我是想把这个钱送出去
但是实在我没能力
我送不出去
我能力不行
理解了吗
打资损不要怪市场
记住了没有
有些东西呢
有些宿命论的东西在里面
你做的时间长了
你就会有这种感觉
就真正的好单子
该你亏的
你一掌都逃不掉
该你赚的
你想弄也弄不了
懂了吗
然后呢
比如说我们假设
现在我们大家都有利润了
对不对
就是有利润的情况下
就不是考虑
就不是考虑止损的问题了呀
现在我们是考虑
如何保护我们的利润
我们的Polofit
怎么去保护它
对不对
所以今天给大家介绍一个工具
在座的各位用MT5的可以跟我说一下
你们用的是MT5有没有人
有人用MT5的
当然MT自上应该也可以
但是因为我方便一点
我就跟你们说MT5的问题
好吧
然后MT5里面有个系统自带的工具
我看一下叫什么东西
叫
叫什么
有一个
我找找看
MT5更新完之后
它是多了一个东西出来的
我想想叫什么名字
唐奇恩通道
我看看
是这个吗
我看一下是不是啊
好像不是这个啊
不是这个
它是一个通道的来着的啊
因为那个我平时看不怎么看啊
但是呢
我可以跟你们说
哎
跑哪去了
怎么找不到了
可能我这个MT5里面没有这个没有这个指标啊它的指标应该MT5里面那个里面有啊就唐奇恩通道20个轴气的这个它的效果应该是这个样子的
就简单来讲就是
20日的最高价和最低价的连线
这个能理解不
就是说20天以前的最低点和20天之内
20天之内的最高价和20天之内的最低价
的一个通道线
我这边好像
我这个软件好像更新过了
里面那个没有了
就是有个像吊灯一样的东西
我看一下这边
我看我这边有没有
那唐旗安通道
就是这个
没有的话
到那个指标库里面应该有的
就MT4官方的MQ5L
MQ105的那个网站上面
可以自己去下载
免费的
懂了吧
这是免费的啊
就是如何我们去保护利润呢
其实我们可以用到这个
比如说我们做多的时候
我们可以用唐前的下限
因为他这个是动态的
懂了吧
就我们比如说这个位置
开了一个多单
我们可以用这个去做我们的指引
就是跟踪指引的动作
比如说前一段时间
比如这波行情
然后我们选择了底部突破
进去以后
上去之后我们有了利润对吧
涨了涨了
后面我们可以跟踪他的什么
20日的下限作为我们的跟踪
明白了吗
就贴到这个黄线走就可以了
贴到这个黄线走
一方面也是帮你
一方面也是帮你有一个持仓的信心
明白了吧
什么时候你要走了呢
两根线跌破
躺前就跌破了
你看
一根下去
第二根破了
你看这个地方你开始拐头了
这个地方你就要小心
这就是推保护的动作
明白了吗
这是比较傻瓜式的
就对那些这个
不知道怎么去调教跟踪指引的
可以用这个方法
明白了吗
当然你也不是一直是用这个
小石头
你根据你的操作周期来说
比如说你四小时进的
你就按照四小时的这个
探前
懂了吧
过段时间它可能往上升
比如说它又长了
再往上升
这边阵一阵
又创新歌了
它再往上升
什么时候呢
什么时候灯触及到这个位置
然后趴击破了
这个时候你就要走了
明白了吗
这是一个利润保护的动作
令人保护的动作
这是一个方法之一
就是你不知道怎么去设跟踪的
就可以按照这个比例来
懂了吧
这是一个跟踪的方法
还有一个方法就是主动指引的方法
我今天也跟你们分享一下
主动指引的方法呢
以做多为例
我们要去看它的上限
就唐奇亚通道的上限
什么叫主动指引呢
给大家解释一下
比如说我们看这个这一波
唐前走平向上然后又走平创新高又走平创新高这些每个地方的节点注意看节点节点之前的那个低点
就是他这个地方
上线往上创新高的前面那个低点
这个地方是创新高的地方
他前面这个地点在这个位置
你在这个地方可以画一个跟踪线
如果后续的行情跌破这个位置的时候
你可以做止盈
懂了吧
你看这个地方
这个点在这
这个地方拐头了
拐头的话
拐头之前的那个低点
设置
那这里后面就没有触发过
这里没触发
到这又来了一次
上线上去了
到这个位置
后面上线就没有上去过
对吧
一直没有创新高
所以这个位置
就是这个阴线的低点
就是你准备溜的地方
指引的位置
就是做多指引
是通过上线去做的
指引是通过上线去做的
然后呢
拉移动止损的话
是通过下线去拉移动止损的
参数就是默然的20
懂了吧
这个好处是什么呢
当你碰到一种
史诗级行情的时候
那
你看一下
史诗级行情
如果你跟踪它
你就不用动了吗
对吧
你看
不动了
到这个地方走了
对不对
那主动止盈的话
就是拐头前的那个高点
拐头前的那个高点
拐头前的那个
这个地方拐头前的那个高点
这里突破你就要走了
这是主动止盈的位置
拐头前的那个高点被突破
唐前的通道的用法
很简单的一个工具
它实质上就是20天线最高
20之内最低
懂了吗
但是有些人呢
他跟你说拿这个去做开仓
那就扯远了
这个东西不是拿来做开仓用的
明白了吧
它实际上其实也就是一个趋势跟踪
只是它去计算的是
最高价和最低价的一个差值
那么这个指标可能平时你们用的不多
它是一个很古老的东西
懂了吗
很古老的东西
还有一个东西就是说
当他们两个
就是上
他的上线和下线离得很远的时候
就是表示行情的级别
懂我意思了吧
就是这个两个空间
就是这个中间的这个直线距离越大
表示起这个趋势的级别能量是很大的
就是高低点之间的这个差
因为他这个上面是20天之内的最高点
20天的最低点对吧
就是H20跟H20的乖离
实质上就是乖离了
对吧
这个差值
级别越大
或甚至超过了之前的这个最大值
那这个行情的级别就会很大
懂了没有
但我们可以去关注它这里的变化
突然放大了
对吗
这边怎么又比这边小呢
注意看
刚开始是从小
就从小变往大变
现在是从大往小变
说明什么
动能在衰退
这个时候你可以通过上下线的一个比例关系去对什么对后续的行情那么一般情况我们看到一个大级别下跌完之后后面又来一个小比较小的
意味着后面可能要震荡了
果不其然你看后面就来了对吗
你看你就算这个最低点到这个位置的时候
和这个最低点到这个位置的时候
哪个大
A大
这是A这是B
A大于B的时候
当它发生反弹完之后
多半是要走横的
走震荡
懂了没有
然后再经过整理
然后转成另外一个趋势
对吧
慢慢的再把这个通道什么展开
懂了没有
还有
当价格
记住
当价格长时间
依附于
某一个上线或下线的时候
比如说大部分是抽
它就粘在这个地方
粘在L2去
就20L的地方
在那边粘着
或者是它粘在这个20H的这个地方
粘在那
它既不突破
又不离开
你看就这个地方
贴着走
这种地方贴着走
你看这种地方贴着走
大家都贴着走的
你看到没有
它并没有离开
这种不离开的情况下面
就是他就是不想往上面去去看
你还跌的时候
他就不想他是这样跌的
他就不想往上去碰上轨
不想去碰
不想碰
就告诉你
没完
懂了吗
没完的
你想一个趋势要改变
连上线都碰不上去
他凭什么涨
换句话说
他连过去20天的最高价都过不去
你怎么能判定他是上涨呢
对不对
实际上我们不用去拿这个
去做这个方向的推移
方向的判断
我们只要今天学会
拿它做什么
做跟踪就可以了
会了吧
今天你学就学两个
你要是想平仓
用上限
多单用上限
空单用下限
你想跟踪用下限
MT4MT5上面自己装一下
这个是免费的
不要钱
好吧
再回来
那么我们现在来看黄金
此时此刻
它的小时的这个叫什么
唐奇安的下限是1847
但1847
也就是我昨天的开仓架附近
对不对
比我是1846开的
它比我的高
所以这个点
我现在就是保本状态了
懂了吗
我的止损就是18
就是我的保本损的位置
所以我就不用担心了
黄线继续往上
继续往上继续往上继续往上继续往上
那么不断的调教
调教你的什么跟踪
懂了不
直到它触及到我们的TP位置
如果在没有打TP之前
先触发的下轨怎么办
我们可以先减一波
懂不
我们可以先减一半吗
落袋为安一点
懂了没有
还留一半
那么进口供退口手
当然最好的情况是什么
一直沿着这个上线
这样再来个上限
再来个上限
直到他达到提平为止
好吧